so uh little washington post it's
something that i think is really cool
about the crux a lot of people worried
about the chronographs
so this is how co 19 can transform the
buildings where we live and work
okay the kovid 19 pandemic has changed
the way we move through space
and some architects say these changes
are creating a new normal
new normal love that love that's my new
favorite one new normal i love how
they're using this upbeat music to make
it like
less dystopian yeah
what this moment brings to us is a
possibility to
rethink everything people are
experiencing a heightened awareness of
their surroundings
and how they interact with their
surroundings cool the hope would be that
we never go back to
pre-covet understanding of the
relationship between
human health and architecture so see
it's a good thing
you see this even though it's like small
businesses are shutting down and this
guy and this woman lost her husband and
stuff
it's a good thing because of get this
from the washington post
architecture i mean i get it but
i didn't realize uh chef royce over here
is the king of making omelets uh without
breaking eggs
and they didn't realize you could just
make omelets without broken eggs i'm
sorry in this case it's breaking eggs
hemorrhaging in your brain
because you're comparing making an
omelet to brain hemorrhages
yeah okay uh you know a lot of people
died during the great leap forward but
you know it was a leap
forward dude they weren't going
backwards
okay she's about to tell us so it's
pretty cool
for most people this heightened
awareness is new but many architects
have been focusing on it for a long time
caitlyn taylor is an architect with a
background in agriculture
and she lives on an organic farm in
connecticut oh my gosh she's challenged
i haven't heard her talk yet
but she already sounds like one of the
most insufferable people
to have a conversation with she sounds
like a miserable lesbian
that's the name of my ska band miserable
lesbian yeah pretty cool
brian long in it yeah uh hello lead
singer lead singer ryan long
miserable lesbians
we got ryan long you know because yeah
he's talented but also because
you know he already fit our visual motif
so he kind of dresses like a visual
lesbian he said hey guys we're all gonna
dress like miserable lesbians
and we're like wait a minute i know a
guy who's already got the clothes
[Laughter]
i love you ryan you know in our 12
13-year history as a firm we've built
our entire model of practice around an
understanding
of the ways in which buildings make
people can make sure
she's so boring even the crickets commit
suicide around her they're just killing
themselves it's this
is this is like i almost feel bad
sometimes with some of these people
because
you meet people like this and then it's
like
you realize like when you go on the
internet sometimes like some people just
report everything they see and they're
insufferable and miserable
and then you see a woman like this and
you're like yeah there's no other way
life would have played out for you
like right you know what i mean like
it's these are the people that spent
their entire
childhood being ignored neglected and
laughed at and picked on
you know how like ellen page has too
much forehead what are we calling you
have too little forehead
uh three head yeah it's just three heads
just no head forehead she should get
together with uh
elliott paige by the way don't worry did
i dead name don't dead did i dead name
don't do that i'm sorry sorry hey hey
elliot sorry bro but she should get with
the big homie elliott
and uh they should work on some kind of
surgical solution thick or that can make
people healthy
in 2011 taylor's firm designed a
hospital
in bhutara rwanda and in 2012 it was
burned to the ground
would be build a hospital like in rwanda
but then not train anybody
just give them everything they need but
then
what does this do they're still
sacrificing babies to get rid of aids
they're opening up people's heads with
bone sauce
obviously this is a saw meant to cut
open your head
so you can let the demons out and you're
like no it's just a headache
just give them ibuprofen one of their
goals was to reduce the transmission of
airborne disease
taylor says the design solutions they
developed were simple but profound
understanding how people travel through
that [ __ ] vocal fry and she was she's
going to be interviewed for this
washington post thing she didn't put a
little bit of makeup on
she's got a lot of makeup on that's a
lot of makeup that's probably her all
dolled up
really what does she look like without
her a ghost
probably yeah she looks like somebody
who's suffering from hypothermia
yeah like ma'am your lips are blue you
know when you become a vampire and
skyrim and every time you walk into it
and then they're always like you look
kind of sick
you're looking pale she by the way is
this woman ever [ __ ] heard of
chapstick
no mike i will answer your question with
the same thing you told me that's her
with all the chapstick she had on
oh my god those lips are that those are
the most chapped lips
i've seen homeless people in new york in
the wintertime with less chapped lips
to be fair she lives in an air fryer
[ __ ] lips look like krispy kreme
donuts like go get some chapstick you
gross
it's very bad they're very [ __ ] bad
and separating people as best you can
when your lips look like sour patch kids
you should probably
get some chapstick oh look how pretty
she is though disgusting
she gives you a blow job and it feels
like a [ __ ] cat is licking your dick
her ears look like the doors on a fancy
car
she's like lamborghini door ears
lamborghini door ears
and lips that are so chapped they look
like pretzels
i'm sorry she's trying to tell us
important things about architecture
she's the best at party lips look like
those cracked [ __ ]
you know the cracked like area like of
the desert like in utah where the
the ground is just cracked somebody's
crawling across their lips going
water water they're seeing mirages of
like
[ __ ] coca-cola machines hey leave
slap city mouth alone
okay she's doing the best she can
she's doing the best she can holy [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] somebody saying holy [ __ ] ashton
birdie fell off hard
still doing better than faked this is
ashton buzzard
[Laughter]
i'm sorry man what were you saying
this is serious okay operating
people as best you can when you know
they're sick
when you know they're contagious with
something involved
moving the i'm sorry one more i have to
apologize if she gives you a [ __ ] she
give your dick rugburn
[Laughter]
she looks like she looks like that girl
in high school that like
you like you know she finally lost her
virginity just because some really
desperate guy
really needed to lose his virginity too
travel through the hospital and
separating people as best you can when
you know they're
sick when you know they're contagious
with something involved
moving the hallways from a single
interior double loaded corridor with bad
airflow i am a doctor
i spent over four months in medical
school
i am ready to go imagine
look at the facilities though they're
nice you know it's a good facility when
they have
mosquito tents mosquito tents and
everybody's in a common area like at
like like a 19th century hospital
this looks like a tuberculosis ward from
like from like boardwalk empire
this is where doc holliday went to die
the window and the relationship between
the windows on one we used to use fly
paper
but unfortunately we ran out of live
paper it is very expensive
to have imported the other side were
like very specifically calibrated to
maximize cross ventilation
the bhutaro district hospital was
effective in part because it was
specifically designed for the
environment where it was built
taylor says this is a design strategy
that should be practiced more widely
especially as architects oh no that's
not a patient that's the president of
the hospital
consider the impact of diseases like
covid19 that's just the
african equivalent of that from the
shriners hospital commercial
they've just the african version
uh as an industry and as a profession at
designing in open dialogue
with the climate and the ecosystem in
which our projects are
an open dialogue with the climate are
you talking to dirt
what dialogue are you having with a
climate yeah why don't you scoot up to
the uh grocery store buy yourself
conditioner so you can design a better
[ __ ] hair
style visa so does why don't you design
and dream about some
less dry hair i look at her hair and i
want to have a shoot
at the okay corral tumbleweed head over
here
[ __ ] handsome hair over here oh bob
hair over here
i hate this woman i hate her guts that's
not true
the dudes from hanson are prettier women
let's run a cone through that [ __ ] at
least she did she keeps breaking them
yeah i'm gonna be told what the future
of the [ __ ] world needs to be
oh we're going to engineer a new future
why you cut your hair with a [ __ ]
flowbee lady
how dare you he's like a [ __ ] pilgrim
yeah seriously how about you design a
[ __ ] buckle for your head
should design something while you design
a hat with a buckle
you [ __ ] [ __ ] how about your
design how about you dream up and design
some small box blankets you [ __ ] dumb
the indians called it maze
oh [ __ ]
i haven't heard a single word she said
i'll be honest i'm sorry now you're
right
[Laughter]
mike you're being very mean no but
seriously somebody actually said her
vocal fry indicate your childhood
oh great lady so now we got to blow up
all the buildings and start over because
you were diddled as a kid i don't think
so lady
i love that kind of time god damn i love
these like ideas to the great reset and
they're like
we're gonna re-imagine all of our
buildings and we're gonna rebuild the
world and it's like [ __ ]
i've been driving down i-95 and driving
across bridges and states all across
america
you can't even keep bridges [ __ ] up
and running you can't even keep the
currently existing infrastructure from
falling apart and you want to blow it
all up and start over
you [ __ ] nuts the same people that
ran the planet into the ground are like
i've got a plan we're gonna start over
and you're like
how many [ __ ] schemes do you have
she looks like she has an everlasting
gobstopper in her mouth at all
times dude the same people right the
same families
that go back 200 years that have been
running this planet the people that
invented slavery are the ones that are
like
we're gonna reimagine the world you're
like what really
there's another guy in this though
nature and humanity are codependent
and i think that this situation that
we're in
i don't know if you know about this guy
he spared no expense
because kane has a mosquito and amber
he looks like one of those art teachers
that like asks you to bring egg cartons
in
and pick and pick through your own
garbage for school he looks like one of
those art teachers where like
there's a rumor he's [ __ ] one of the
students anybody's like yeah i heard mr
johnson
yeah i heard mr hall's [ __ ] all the
all the sophomore girls
like like the great composer arvo part
who uh mike our whole party
[ __ ] slaps
you don't got his mixtape dude he did a
song with kanye like the great composer
timberland he said but mike what about
magoo
what about magoo is dope i know goo
didn't get enough
what happened to him somebody says
he looks like craig t nelson
well when i was done with coach i found
the great reset was a passion of mine
that about it it sends us all back to
the first grade
and uh hey look it's alternate universe
julian assange the one where he's
where trump pardoned him because we've
spent the last
a few decades uh basically wrecking
the earth we've spent the last few
decades wrecking the earth you hear that
i'm working on a project in bogota for
the doctorate's college
and it's about if you're working on any
project in bogota it's a cover for a
cook
for a cocaine business oh good more
post-modern misery
what are you talking about you don't
like that no no i love uninspired
[ __ ] straight lines all over the
place i love it you don't like that the
future looks like minecraft yeah i don't
like that the future looks like
[ __ ] self-assembled furniture from
amazon
[ __ ] ikea buildings literally an
amazon desk
all right there's one more person that i
want we gotta check out and then we
gotta go break
would be um full of furniture
and almost a kit of tools so it's a
marriott like what's so impressive
that's what it was it's like the lobby
of a marriott
no it's one of the ones that has a tiny
fitness center the microchip the
microgym
sorry yeah one we have one machine that
can be
and it's always out of order manipulated
by the individual
and in many cases might even be relying
upon
a bring your own device policy so that
you aren't even touching anything could
that device be in them
no i know what you want to say i stopped
i know what you want to say
i stopped i stopped so the future of
businesses would be
basically desk and you have to bring
your own [ __ ] from home
so then why not just work from home
what's the point what's the point of
going into work
will we be getting raises or any sort of
uh i don't know
uh recompensation for oh no we're asking
salary to take a 10
pay cut actually oh great good
it's like that world economic forum
thing where they're like you'll own
nothing and be happier for it and it's
like oh
gee great you're simply bringing what
you already have
on hand because it's supplied by your
employer and you're unlocking the
potential of
different screens or whiteboards or
no no no no no no stop stop pretending
like this is a good thing
stop pretending like you're suddenly
going to start letting people express
themselves at work again yeah because
that's not going to be
like oh it's going to be great you're
going to buy your own [ __ ] so we don't
have to buy it
but you can express yourself but
obviously within the framework that we
set for you
uh and we still won't be allowing you to
display any sort of individuality or
wrong thing
so you get nothing you're just it's just
a roundabout way of making you pay for
your own desk
well will you have at least a microwave
i could use to eat my lunch up
uh no oh okay
will we be permitted to bring food into
the building absolutely no
no through an app that's on your phone
and you have a choice of working at you
know a bigger table
to draw or write or exchange thoughts
with
colleagues or on a couch
i'm sorry what are you reading you you
reinvented what
having a table yeah did you did you
invent a couch
look the more this goes on the uh
mark my words i'm gonna get myself i
just want everybody to know this
uh i'm only telling you this now
so that you can clip this and save it
and i'm telling you in advance
please don't get all bent out of shape
or think that i i just don't
want to do this anymore so if i just end
up you know eating a bullet
this is going to be why because i don't
want to deal with these nerds running
the planet i can't do it we're there my
friend we're already not
covet 19 has been devastating as tupac
said
don't shed a tear i ain't happy here
[Laughter]
as tupac also said that's why i [ __ ]
your [ __ ] you fat [ __ ] exactly
couch
coveted 19 has been devastating but
architects say there's
also some hope hope that this tragedy
wakes people up to the changes that were
needed long he says royce is honestly
worried i'm not mike's mistakes
as long as i've known him yeah i'm i'm
not worried i'm waiting for
it yeah it's just it's a matter of like
when not if
yeah before the pandemic if we take one
thing
from this crisis is that you're
irredeemably ugly
yeah that's the one thing i've taken
from this video
she's one of those [ __ ] chicks that
like i'm
sure if you were in a really cold streak
and you were just losing your swag you
might do it
but there's like there's the girls that
you would [ __ ] just to get
your swag back and maybe get a little
kick in your step
but like after you [ __ ] them you're like
i can't believe i did that this is one
of those ones that even while you're
[ __ ] her you're like i can't believe
i'm doing this
she looks like she went to school with
tom sawyer
she looks like tom sawyer she looks like
huck finn
she looks like uh she looks like brad
renfrow now
she looks like huck finn but she [ __ ]
n-word gym and then accused him of
she does look like hulk finn though she
looks like jonathan taylor thomas all
grown up
all right
we gotta get to break here um let me
read uh some
kevin says i'd hit 23 times a day i love
nerdy looking chicks
i hear your point sir but you know
they're there are cute nerdy chicks
right
attractive ones that don't look terrible
she looks like
she's been left out on a drying rack for
[ __ ] weeks
she looks like the human equivalent of
jerky she looks like
distressed wood she looks like
like she looks like what meat used to
look like before refrigeration
when they just had to coat it in salt
and hang it up at a [ __ ] barn
she looks like something you would buy
urban outfitters
she looks like an old navy jacket you
know what i mean
if that makes sense i don't even think
it does i know i get it i actually do
an old navy jacket she's the human
equivalent of an old
navy jacket oh [ __ ] this is what happens
when you buy plethora not real leather
exactly this is what you get she looks
like an amazon futon
you said this was leather and we said no
i said it was like
all right enough it's being mean you're
now at this point it's gratuitous